Justice Department issued a new warning
about government leaks Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein said in a
statement quote Americans should be
skeptical about anonymous allegations
the statement comes amid reports Special
Counsel Robert Muller is widening his
investigation he is reportedly looking
into the finances and business dealings
of Jared Kushner president Trump's
son-in-law and advisor major Garrett is
at the White House major good morning
good morning the Deputy Attorney
General's language echoes the
president's disdain for reporting on the
Russian probe it may also be an attempt
to begin to question the conduct and
credibility of the special counsel
himself something that White House
allies have been trying to do all week
meanwhile the vice president as the
saying goes as lawyer up the strength of
our nation will be determined by our
ability to keep jobs in America even as
President Trump talked about jobs his
frustration with the ongoing and
seemingly expanding Russia
investigations boiled over why is it
that Hillary Clinton's family and
Demme's dealings with Russia are not
looked at but my non dealings are the
president asked on Twitter another tweet
called a probe the greatest witch hunt
in American political history mr.
president do you believe that you are
under investigation now the White House
repeatedly referred all Russia questions
to the president's personal attorney
mark according to the Washington Post
mr. Trump's son-in-law Jared Kushner
also a top White House adviser is now
under special counsel scrutiny the Post
said Robert Muller is investigating
Kushner's finances and business dealings
in a statement to CBS News Kushner's
attorney said that Kushner had not been
contacted by the special counsels office
mr. Kushner previously volunteered to
share with Congress what he knows about
Russia related matters and quote he will
do the same if he is contacted in
connection with any other inquiry thank
you mr. secretary in a sign of the
newfound seriousness of Muller's
investigation vice president Pence's
office confirmed Thursday that he too
had hired a lawyer to deal with a
special counsel investigation
today the president will fly to Miami to
scale back the reopened diplomatic
contacts between the United States and
Cuba in Miami the
president will reimpose some limits on
American travel and business
transactions that were relaxed when
those diplomatic relations were
reestablished Jeff major thank you